let's talk about missing weapons from
modern warfare some of your fears about
engine changes in warzone and why some
of you are going to wait for call of
duty or battlefield later this year
i'm joined here by richie bracamonte and
what we're going to do in this episode
is we're going to look at your comments
broken into your hopes your fears and
what some of you are going to do next
as always if you guys like joining us
for these call of duty chats give us a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
it really helps us out
let's start off with your hopes now many
of you had comments that you're holding
out
hope that modern warfare will keep going
or at least there'll be some content
added to modern warfare if you stick
with it
so we've got some user comments from our
last video here's one from ghillie7 over
on youtube
he says well there's three weapons being
added to modern warfare i found the lmg
in survival mode and the challenges to
unlock it
but it makes sense that they're saving
soap and the rest of the stuff for
modern warfare 2
in 2022 and he's right there are
some unannounced guns that have made
their way into survival mode and you can
find their challenges to unlock them
we don't know when they're officially
going to come out but they've been
bugged into the game somehow we've got a
new lmg
the scorpion returns and the the cycop
pistol
it's sort of weird how this is all
happening and how it hasn't been patched
it's a sign of
things to come we're sure we just don't
know when the official announcement and
the official rollout of these guns is
going to happen
we have no idea it's interesting that
those weapons are
already in the game which begs the
question like when were they supposed to
have been added to the game was this a
bug
or cut content from the end of the
modern warfare seasons
or was this something that they had
intended to add at a future date and
delayed
the other really big question is soap
right so there was a cut scene at the
end of the modern warfare storyline in
warzone
where soap was like offshore and
something was going badly
and it didn't seem like it was zombies
when that cutscene happened
um which is what's happening on the map
now so what's going on with soap
so what's your position
things are really hitting up out here
outside there was a soap
uh operator bundle that sort of leaked
but it hasn't officially been ruled out
and the question is
why like what's the holdup and it could
be a factor of things
like the uh they kind of want the
zombies portion to cool off for a bit
before they reintroduce soap in some
sort of cool way
or another rumor is the launch of modern
warfare 3 remastered that would be a
great time to launch the soap bundle
just like they did with
ghost and modern warfare 2 remastered
back in season 2. so they could be
holding out for that
it's it's kind of unfortunate that the
guns have made their way into the game
but
no soap operator bundled just yet and
we're all waiting
he's gonna go away
so it seems that some of you guys are
concerned about the future of cold war
and how it will continue to take over
warzone
so over on youtube we've got another
comment from laurenboy who says
i just don't want them to switch the
warzone engine because i love modern
warfare's engine
and aaron i think you and i both agree
that we do too
yeah we saw this comment actually quite
a lot in our last video and i i think i
can put your mind to ease it's not very
likely that a game can switch engines
it's it's
kind of not even physically possible a
lot of times so the way that game
development works like you know we spent
years talking to developers
depending on the engine that they're
using for example um i'll use
battlefield because we cover a lot of
battlefield
so engines are math and science and duct
tape they don't work
conceptually the way that you think that
reality works for example in a game like
hardline in order to let people lean out
windows they had to take up an animation
slot which is why they had to get rid of
bipods on lmgs
so you know like engines don't work
within reality and they are hard to
change
and almost impossible to change after a
game has been released
modern warfare does i would say have a
more advanced engine than cold war they
were probably developed
somewhere next to each other and it was
impossible for cold war to switch later
on
but you did see cold war try and take on
things that the modern warfare engine
could do
like doors and armor and things like
that and it didn't quite work probably
because it wasn't natural to that engine
when it started so if you're concerned
that the cold war takeover
of war zone is going to lead to an
engine change i would say that's highly
unlikely what's more likely
is that the next call of duty game will
take the modern warfare engine
and have a much smoother integration and
hopefully be a little bit more you know
well thought out than
the way they just kind of jammed all
this together so i wouldn't worry about
that one
and again we saw a lot of people
commenting this i think if you like
modern warfare and the way it feels
warzone is going to stay that way for a
long time so it's no small ask to switch
to an entirely new engine
but there are some things that cold war
picked up that are cool and that would
probably work
really well over into warzone and
the two things i'm thinking of
specifically are swimming
because that's still it's still so silly
that you can't swim you just die
uh and also the field of view slider
there have been
you know countless people asking for it
and
since cold war can do it it'd be cool to
see you know warzone try it out like
i think you know pc's already got that
down no problem but for everyone else
it's hard to go back to something like a
regular field of view when you have
the extended field of view in cold war
it's been such a great it's been a great
addition and
i'd love to see that in war zone i think
you would do aaron yeah also
like the boundaries that are drawn
around verdansk are weird
and they're weird because of water and
you really notice it like when you're
trying to parachute to the
to the zombie ship now and you get out
over water you
you get out of bounds and you
potentially die i'm assuming that that
is because you can't swim
currently with a modern warfare engine
i've even occasionally had a
someone in warzone try and murder me by
driving a car into the ocean
so it'd be nice if i could swim
i think that's happened to all of us
okay so here's the other thing about
your your fears about what's happening
to war zone right now
i don't know if um warzone can pull off
like this hastily what it seems to be
doing from treyarch's influence
so the zombie event right now is
odd like there was a tease recently that
the zombies were spreading
but then nothing really happened for a
week and they're infecting the gulag now
and they also did things that say it was
done hastily to me on the map such as
they closed all the subways on the map
during the zombie outbreak but
it would have been so much better if
they'd done the opposite of that what
what if they had opened
the subways and infested them with
zombies and
you know like richie you and i were
talking about this yesterday the zombies
were like getting electrocuted on the
tracks and
yeah that would have been so much more
exciting of an event and
we've had better like the haunting of
our dance was all over the map and had
so many amazing locations
and since we've had better and now we're
seeing this ship crash and like a fairly
minimal thing happening it makes me
wonder how long it's going to take for
this event to build up to something
larger
again like we're early and it might
happen but i'm starting
to question whether it's going to be as
big or whether the nuke is even at the
end of the season like
what if we're still a couple seasons out
from the nuke the nukes
been supposed to happen for a while now
like i'm weirdly less concerned this
week about the cold war takeover just
because i
it doesn't seem to be having as large of
an impact as it could have right now
i agree they've been holding this nuke
event out for way too long and
tomorrow as the time of at the time of
recording this video tomorrow
is the one year anniversary so
something's got to give the event's
going to be over that's one thing
but you know let's see here's to a big
change to verdance you know let's
let's put all the cards down you know
see i'm excited to see what's happening
if something happens so the next thing
we'd like to talk about is uh like a lot
of our top comments
when we're still kind of on the fear
side of things is about
greed and then like understandably i
think a lot of people question
activision so this comment by kenneth
905 was
this is exactly why cod needs to stop
being an annual franchise
but active blizzard only cares about
money so
yeah so yeah this also ties back into
uh some interesting points that have
been made by other youtubers about
the missing weapons in modern warfare so
the theory was they started scattering
these missing weapons on the ground or
other weapons on the ground of war zone
to get you to want to go to the store
and buy them um so here's what i have to
say about that
vote with your wallet i you know i think
people have heard this a million times
but there was some great news recently
where ea
not the company that makes this but e8
who who's very notorious for this stuff
basically just gave their own developers
free reign to make the next titanfall
or make the next dragon age without
their sort of overbearing business
practices and that's because a lot of
you
um didn't buy those games or a lot of
you had backlash against battlefront 2.
so i would say definitely vote with your
wallet i haven't had any motivation to
buy anything from the call of duty store
since cold war took over
if you don't engage with the store right
now or you just engage with the modern
warfare store you're making it
pretty clear to them that you just want
modern warfare and you don't want cold
war i know it's cliche but vote with
your wallet on these ones
the one catch to that is is don't be a
dick you know like
being uh firm but friendly in life will
get you very far
you know don't go harass dabs or be a
jerk to anybody you know they work
really hard in these games too
so those were some of your fears about
the future of war zone and cold war
let's talk about some of those people
who are just moving on
we've got a comment here from dylan who
says two to three years and another new
modern warfare
that one kind of stings because uh aaron
aaron and i both love
2019 modern warfare for sure and the
cycle goes on you know this past year
was cold war
this year is supposed to be sledgehammer
we're not sure how this is going to go
down you know it could be any time
period
they can make a sequel to their world
war ii game they can make a sequel to
advanced warfare they can do something
new
but that's just how the cycle goes and
we're not sure what's gonna happen next
but we will find out soon enough
so the other side of that is battlefield
a lot of you said
you know what that's cool modern warfare
drew me in because i'm a milsim fan
i'm gonna wait for the next battlefield
so some of the comments along that lines
were
dark titan said say hello to battlefield
6. fingers crossed if they don't f it up
i want 2011 air battlefield greatness
you know
i'm going to tie this into another
comment here and then we'll talk about
it this individual with a long string of
numbers i will not attempt to pronounce
said good video uh keep up the good work
i love these kinds of videos also can
you guys talk about battlefield 6
having three studios working on it what
that's referring to is is battlefields
being developed by daisola dice
stockholm
and now criterion has been brought in
but i think what both of these comments
are getting at is also fears about
battlefield like you know
battlefield has been in in various
states in the past
battlefield 4 launched pretty rough
here's what i have to say about the new
battlefield it seems like it's going to
have a modern setting and a lot of the
things that attracted you to modern
warfare will attract you
probably to this battlefield bringing in
criterion is a little bit of a mixed
message
i can't take credit for these all these
thoughts on my own i was watching a
little bit of westie's videos who covers
a lot of battlefield so my perspective
on criterion is that they did an
incredible job on the battlefront series
particularly in the controls of the game
like they're so good at vehicle controls
they're really good at air controls they
did an x-wing vr game
so if criterion is coming in to help
them with the vehicle controls of their
game
that's exciting and some of you push
back on that when i said it before
because you really do like battlefield's
controls
what i have to say about that is the
controls are hard to learn
but if you master them you're going to
be really really good there just aren't
a lot of good
people who fly in battlefield because
they're tough and criterion can fix that
what westy was saying
was that criterion might just be you
know getting brought in
um as just you know hands to help dice
stockholm finish it
and it sounds like dice la is mostly
working on their
live game aspect of it so it seems like
stockholm does still have a lot of
control over this project
dice la's had to bail them out in the
past the other thing criterion
helped on was with firestorm so there's
like this even other option that they're
just basically helping them finish up
their
their battle royale which hopefully
won't be
you know locked behind a pay wall this
time so there's a lot going on there
like there's there's a lot of hope that
a battlefield will come out later this
year and the modern warfare players who
don't like cold war style
can gravitate to that and there's mixed
messaging going on basically
dice saying that battlefield's in a
fantastic place but also oh my god we
need more people to help us come in
and finish it so good luck with that i
would say it's a good sign that they're
getting help in any way they can get it
they they need help they need support
they need people working on it
make it the best game they possibly can
and uh it's cool we'll
we'll be able to live in a world with uh
you know uh
battlefield and call of duty once again
i mean not that that stopped happening
but
this last year has just been war zone
you know like it's it's hot right now
yeah so there's a lot of possibilities
this year and i again like i'm very
hopeful because
you can stick with modern warfare some
people said in the comments um you can
keep playing warzone and kind of hope
that
changes don't take over too much and
that there's still content for
modern warfare to come or you can you
know jump ship to
battlefield when that comes out
hopefully at the end of this year early
next year
or you know you can wait for that next
modern warfare title
again like you're gonna have a lot of
options and we'll keep covering all
these games as they come out
we're expecting some big reveals this
spring and we're gonna have a much
better idea and you'll have a much
better idea
of what you want to do after watching
those so head on over to gamespot
head on over to gamespot's youtube page
and give us a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel
to let us know that you're enjoying what
we're doing alright
thanks for watching everybody
you